est ce que cette hybridation justement
est bien perçu également dans la société
jusqu'où va-t-on dans les mythes le
mythe du centaure de l'homme oiseau
on voit aussi dans les films de science
fiction que nos jeunes aiment beaucoup
avec les mutants dès lors qu'on est
quand même différent même si on a des
super pouvoirs
et bien justement on est encore
catégoriser et on peut être ségrégué
c'est pas l'individu réduit à son corps
c'est l'individu avec justement son
esprit sa moralité sa vie sociale bref
faut voir l'homme sur un tout est ce
tout il est comme vous avec ses
différences n'oubliez pas que le sport
c'est l'égalité au départ pour mieux
accepter et l'inégalité une fine et je
pense que les personnes en situation de
handicap notamment les sportifs de haut
niveau en station de handicap ne
recherche qu'une chose c'est la
reconnaissance qu'on leur homologue
walid est en fait le fait qu'on traite
d'un sportif ou une sportive en soit son
handicap parce qu'il est en situation de
handicap
ça montre bien qu'on n'y est pas encore
mais c'est sûr que c'est sûr le rêve ce
serait que juste on parle de sport
alors voilà on parle de sport alors
c'est du cdu c'est du football c'est de
la tétine c'était du handball bastien la
céleste l'athétisme est que avec un
amputé tibial la cdc du football avec un
jeune avec un jeune du 16 la sig du
badminton en double voilà un point c'est
tout ce serait juste ça